françois hollande bonsoir concevoir
répondu à notre invitation vous avait
ironisé sur ce que vous appelez l'appel
au secours de l'ump au modem vous avez
affirmé qu'il n'y a pas de stratégie
d'alliance entre le parti socialiste et
le modem c'est pas tout à fait ce que
nous a dit ségolène royal hier qu'on
comprend mal qui décide au parti
socialiste
et quelle est la consigne mais la chose
est simple nous avons fait nous 48 ou 49
% des voix vous avez rappelé les
chiffres
donc s'il faut avoir une majorité il le
faudra bien au second tour c'est autour
de nous si on veut voter clairement pour
un changement que les électeurs vont se
mobiliser si parmi les candidats il y en
a qui veulent venir avec nous sur notre
projet avec nos alliances à gauche est
clairement dans une opposition à la
politique de nicolas sarkozy
ils seront les bienvenus y compris des
candidats du modem s'ils sont sur ses
positions là mais je note bien où vous
avez donné beaucoup de reportages qu'il
ya autant de position du modem qu'il y a
deux villes en france
alors pas besoin de faire une alliance
quelconque il s'agit simplement pour nos
candidats ville par ville d'être dans
cet état d'esprit c'est à dire vouloir
le changement dans la clarté et en
rassemblant au plus large
est-ce que vous avez la possibilité dans
certaines villes d'attendre comme ça
sereinement que le modem viennent à vous
et non pas d'aller vers le modem dans
des villes comme saint-etienne ou comme
strasbourg ou encore comme marseille ou
le résultat est quand même très serré et
finalement les l'appui du modem pourrait
vous aider à faire basculer ses villes
dans votre camp d'abord nous avons
commencé à nous adresser à nos alliés
naturels
a strasbourg les verts à paris bertrand
delanoë avec ses anciens adjoints verts
quand même un peu plus tranquille à
paris
rio est le même à strasbourg nous sommes
dix ans au large mais quand même nous
gardons cet état d'esprit d'abord nos
alliés naturels
puis après les autres sur des listes qui
peuvent être diverses à dire pas
simplement modem ya aussi des listes
plus à gauche qui disent bas nous
voulons aussi participer un travail au
plan local
nous ne partageons pas toutes vos
convictions mais en même temps nous
pensons que sur les transports sur le
logement sur l'accueil de la petite
enfance
on peut changer la vie au quotidien dès
à présent ça c'est notre état d'esprit
venir sur un projet avec des alliances
qui sont à gauche est clairement dans
l'opposition à nicolas sarkozy par la
majorité et par la voix des élus et nt
vous accuse de préparer ce que jean
françois copé appelle une tva municipal
c'est à dire d'être le parti qui fera
exploser les impôts locaux
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cette
accusation je trouve ça cocasse que le
pouvoir actuel qui a augmenté
considérablement les prélèvements ces
dernières années jamais le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires et n'a été
aussi élevée face maintenant je ne sais
quelle polémique sur attention si la
gauche et tulle elle va augmenter les
impôts
vous savez dans quelles villes
religieuses sont rares ou pas dans
quelle ville de france
les impôts sur les plus élevés c'est à
bordeaux alain juppé de néanmoins a été
lu 1
mais ce n'est pas la gauche qui
augmentent les impôts c'est la droite au
plan national mais je vais prendre un
engagement parce que je veux que les
choses soient claires moi je défends le
pouvoir d'achat des français et je
considère aujourd'hui qu'il ya une
nécessité à maîtriser les tarifs publics
l'eau l'assainissement et à faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas d'augmentation
de la fiscalité alors qu'on vienne pas
nous chercher là dessus parce que en
revanche ce dont je suis sûr c'est qu'au
lendemain des élections municipales
compte tenu de l'ampleur des déficits
publics de la sécurité sociale du
ralentissement de la croissance il ya
bien des mesures qui se prépare nicolas
sarkozy appelle ça a justement moi j'ai
pas de sa plan de rigueur je vous
interromps pascal instant une
information qui vient de tomber les
listes du modem sont en train de
fusionner avec celle du parti socialiste
à marseille c'était déjà le cas dans les
villes comme chartres et asnières c'est
que ce genre de rapprochement est tout à
fait envisageable sur les basses que
j'ai indiqué c'est pas étonnant
d'ailleurs à marseille le reportage
rappelé que jean luc bennahmias et l
ancien dirigeant des verts à ses valeurs
une nouvelle série ce ralliement du
modem à marseille sur le projet de jean
noël guérini je préfère des fusions de
listes sur la clarté sur des projets
politiques plutôt que la lettre de
nicolas sarkozy qui arrive sur le bureau
de jean claude gaudin à la veille d'un
scrutin
écoutez franchement je préfère la clarté
politique que l'on pro lieu y compris
par voie de courrier merci à françois
hollande